car
フォトショップです
いや photoshop 本当にすごいですね
プロの手腕ですねどんな奴が出てくるかと思ったらこんな違って聴いてしまいました
はいちょっとこんな訳表ですねあのーせっかく小堀したので皆さんとお友達なのかなと
思っています
先ほどご紹介だったと思う
んですけれども私5年で同4年生ですね
なんでそんなことが起こるかというと2年間休学しているからです
今も休学しています2年間休学するとどういうことが起こるでしょうか
先輩卒業します同期卒業します1個した凸行します友達全然いなくなっちゃうね
めざ寂しいわけですしかも来年の4月から大学行かなきゃいただき知ってる全然外で
待っちゃうわけですね
そういうことで私は今日は何かの縁でここでこうして皆さんに生えたわけですからお
友達ので借りたいなぁと思っているわけです
私がつけない人は好奇心が旺盛でワクワク毎日を匹4点でしたです
私も自分はそういう人間でありたいと思う
そういう意味であるためには何を大事ですか
私は
これだと思います
当たり前を疑って新しい考えて吸収する
私はこれを心がけるようになってから
はい前景的な優等生タイプとか私の学生生活は一気に超ワクワクするものへの展望も
増えてきました
ハイサイコメで今日は考える90する当たり前を疑うことについてお話ししたいのか
まずは私がなぜ総合22位だったがそのきっかけとなったエピソードをご紹介します
まあ用正絹食話をさかのぼりたいと思います
まあじゃあ c なっています乳の母の父はですね本当に怖いんですよちょっとした事
ですぐとなる計濃厚さんでですね
あの鬼の生まれ変わりなんじゃないかなってぐらい強いんですね
じゃあも私はところにが通りだして怒られたくないということで怒られない新刊を研究
しましたその結果
できてをしている時と大内のお手伝いをしているだけは怒られないということができ
ました
そして母阻ま優しいお母さんなんですけれども
あの人の迷惑になることをやるんじゃないの
口を酸っぱくして言っていました
まぁこんな容姿の影響がですね私はこのように1人ベラをかけず勉強 is in 成績
をとってそんで人も役に立つというのが自分の役で最高の目標
西光院絶対に揺るがないものというふうに認識するようになりました
まああのこういう風に考えるっていうのは結構工場にとってはつらい御んですね
このような目も森羅小学校生活を送るという結果になってしまいました
私はこの価値観を幼少期から大学に入るまでずっと持ち続けでそういうことを言うと戦
です
天気を食べます
大学二世13勝つイメージに上る
少し前道です
私はファーストステップとプログラムというものに参加しました
これは何かというとですねあの北大が主催してるんですけれども
海外でまぁいって清香
大学とか国際光を訪問させてくれる
いろんな人の話を聞かせてもらいもそういうプログラムんですねえそういうプログラム
に行くとですね
アクセは絶対強く質問します
学生時代は何をやったらいいミッション変わっているニューですね
で
私は
あのーそのお話を聞いた皆さんみんなの女し答えるというすごくびっくりしますこれ
です
好きな子なんでも屋皆さんどんどん自分の好きなペン
a と思いました今まで私が持った方しかも全然違うことをオススメされている
えっ
好きなことやったら人に目をかけこちらないし
16日使うと褒めるんですか
そんなことやるの方はしちゃダメでしょという風にして最初はこの考え方を持ってる
拒絶していました
いやこういうふうにアートを拒絶したわけなんですけれども
自分の価値観と違うことをおすすめされるって言うのは
中野がちょっと衝撃的な低てんなもんでですね
その好きなことをやりなさいという言葉がずっと私は心の中に残っています
そして帰国後を考えてみましたっ
私好きなことを何だろう
おっ
そしたら衝撃的な結果が出てしまいました
私好きでも即になかったんです
それ20すごく勝負を受けいましたん
品物遠くになるんじゃない
その金で生きてるのっ
もう今まで生きる価値だと思っていた価値観さんもそこで歌が走りました
でも新しい価値観もまだ信じることができない私の生きる力一体どこにあるんだろう
そういうふうにして2ヶ月間訪問と悩み続けました
そしたりラっと一つやりたいことができます
それをあまり考え過ぎた場合が進みタイプ4
ああああああ
はい
休み咲くのか私はでも今までも考えたらしたそれを特に人の役に立つことでもないので
やらない方がいい
でも
ここで新しい考えをちょっとだけ新車寝ようかなと思いました
そこで私はベッドに入りました
始まったのころです冬眠ですよ
私は透明することにしましたホーミーて強欲音が鳴りますとベッドに入りますねます朝
起きます
そしたらん
天井面をそれを午後4時ぐらいまでずっとこのまま
あっているんです
無理してやってがおけるなりますなんか本より質などそんな時間になっちゃう
しかも私はこれを4ヶ月間も続けました
8日です時間にすると2040自動です
北海道の最低賃金が同約155名を稼ぐことができるし彼も私は寝る某店の政令市
その結果
その結果どうなんたかかりますとは8カ月の続けてある
あもう十分な須川なぁと思ってきた
そこでベットからものを持っ
したらです
すっごく心が軽くなってるんです
そしてアーム自分が8ヶ月前に考えていったことに思いをさせました
そしたら新しい館前何でもられて横浜へ
でも洋画でなんです
まんでもやったいいじゃんかどこへ応用になることです
なんでこのでていただける人がここまでは行かなかった
私は例えば
その今まではその新しい考えというのを自分が持っている考え心から離れない考えを
もとにしていいマレーと判断していたものと思うんです
しかし同じあこの後やと透明するというのを経て二つの考えどっちも客観的にとらえ
られるそういう自分の中で余裕ができたんだなと思います
これが私が新しい考え自分がに一生を得られないと思っていた
考えを覚えて新しい考えを受け入れた瞬間でした
そこから面白くて自分がこんなに変わっていくということが本当に面白くてそこから
どんどんどんどん新しい考えくれてそれを吸収していくんしました
草原が私は自分を方に2つの良い循環ができた
2つの入りループがでしたなそういうことに気がつきました
それをご紹介したいと思います
一つ
仲良し増え超取るとです
みてくださいスターウォーズ電話
新しい考えを吸収するというものです
新しい考えに出会って吸収するとどうなるのできるか
色込型紙です
そしたらイオンの意見を尊重できるようになります
遅く心の中でもうや涼子とも生まれてくるわけです
そうなるといろんな人と仲良くできるようになっ
そうすれば交友関係がが張っていいよなってまた新しい
考えるであることができます
これが仲良し増えちゃうる
皆さん考えてみてください
自分が慎重になって言いたいことをろ過して濾過して相手のことを気遣って話さなきゃ
いけない相手よりも
自分の言いたいことを垂れ流し3できるが入ってることが下げて抱くじゃった
そういうあいけばも喋って楽しいと思いますし
家があってそういうことだと思います
またそういう人のことをそういう人をまた会いたい人って思う
この学科やし future グループに入ると自分が相手にそういう人なんだって
思ってもらえるようにだけじゃないかと思っています
もう一つがあっ
どんどん飛び込むぞルームです
出発点は内緒新しい考えに触れたその吸収しますするとどうなんだ
一つの物事をいろんな方向から見ることができるようになります
そうなると予想外の出来事マイナスな出来事セア
いろんな方向かられてある時ポジティブな偏官を捉えられるん
そうすると失敗を添えるとなります
失敗すら学びの起点と考えられております
そこから物おじしない度胸がついていろんな新しい感じで取り込む力になります
新しい環境に飛び込んだと思う
今後はまた新しい考えを吸収することができます
これがどんどん飛び込むぞルームです
仲良し増えちゃうドループとどんどん注ぎ込むそりゅ
あ
視点な人ですスタートしていた人ですなのでこれをくっつけることができます
無限ルールです
中谷袖飛び込んください占める飛び込む
いいことしか起きてるというループにでは私は入っています
こう無限ループに入ってから私は予想外のことを自分の考えから外れたことを楽しめる
し
そうすると毎日が発見の連続でワクワクすることが断然増えました
もっとワクワクしたいそう思った私はいろんな工房を起こすようになりました
例えば人中間ユースフォーラムという
日中韓の学生が集まって参加小平印字話しちゃう頃の運営をやったり
をキャンプオールドサムとという世界190カ国から生300人の若者が集まり試み
参加したいっ
自分の勉強している分があの政治と宗教について勉強してるんですけれどもその分野の
勉強を深めるのは犬を後ろやしとけに芳樹著リングいくぜろ剣とに留学していたり
ただ留学で還元して飛び立て留学 japan ということにも応募しました
これして見てますか食べたて優雅ジャパンは結構居ますねありがとうございます
飛び立て留学者フォンというのが海外に行く学生に対して奨学金を与えてくれるという
プログラムを作っています
しかしその他にを応募してきた学生たちのネットワークというものに参加することが
あっ
飛び立てゲルが別役は私は1期生なんですか
1期生は三百数十人
この人たちがはが面白いうユニークなひな子ばっかりで私は彼らかに新しい感覚
たくさんもらいました
あとは一つよだったんですが学生ばっかりと喋ってるのも新しい考えとく
お墓ができてを醸しれるなと思ったので音馬が人と喋りたいと思ってつなぐでバイトし
始めました
スタッフのお客さんからもたくさんの新しい考えをもらえます
さて a
私は今新しい考え出会い
収集するこういうことが大事と繰り返し言ってきました
しかしそれは新しい考えばかりがいい
と言っているわけではありません
また今まで持っていたもの一般的に良いと言われている感じ
それをダメだと言ってるわけでますます
ただ
皆さんが今やりたいことがあっです
それに歯止めをかけているのが自分の当たり前だと思っている考えるんでした
ん
その間から本当に自分にとって正しいのか
疑ってみてください
そして疑うことでまた新しい住むな見栄を張って
私たち学生は自分のために使える時間がたくさんあります
自分のために考える時間もたくさん
だから学生であるん
今こそ私たちは新しい乾杯をたくさん吸収して当たり前を疑っていくべきなんじゃない
ですか
最後にですね
私も妹言ったことに対して今まで言ってきたことに対して賛成の人も流師範隊が人も
いると思うんです
どちらも大切な価値観ですみなさんの考えを私に教えてください
私は人から言われた事をすぐにはねのけたりすることは絶対にしません
せっかく後最初にはいかんですけどせっかく何とかえでここで出会えているわけですか
仲良く飲んで帰りたいなって思い
当たり前を疑って新しい考えをどんどん吸収し
発見と爆発に満ち世界を一緒に楽しんでいけませんかありがとうございました